- Got awful quiet in here all of a sudden.
I'm Bill, product manager
for AWS DevOps Agent.
I'm gonna be joined here
on stage later by David,
who's a senior principal
engineer here at AWS.
And a little bit about
David before I start,
before he comes on a little bit later.
David's been part of the teams
that have built AWS services
like DynamoDB, Lambda, IoT, CloudWatch.
He's also as a senior principal engineer
and been at Amazon for
nearly 20 years now.
Been one of the people
that's really shaped
the DevOps culture at Amazon and AWS,
so he publishes weekly inside of AWS
to all of our AWS and Amazon builders,
a blog called, "This
Week in Observability."
He's also been a primary
contributor to something
called the Amazon or AWS Builder Library.
Is anybody familiar with the
Builder Library out there?
A few of you.
So that's where we publish in-depth pieces
on how Amazon approaches
building and operating software.
And I checked last night, David.
David's authored 11 of those articles.
I think he's the most
prolific author on that site.
So I do encourage you to look at those.
A lot of really interesting
and helpful information there.
And so I say all of that
because we've been really lucky
to have David be part of the team
that's helped us build
the AWS DevOps Agent
over the past year, so his
fingerprints are all over it.
A lot of the culture, the
DevOps culture that he's tried
to infuse into the AWS
and Amazon development
and operations teams has been poured
into the DevOps Agent itself.
And so the other thing
I wanted to say, I said,
David's a senior principal
engineer and at Amazon.
Some of you might be
wondering what is that?
What does a senior principal
engineer at Amazon really do?
And it's actually, it's
kind of a big deal,
but like what's the day
in the life of David?
And so if you were one of those people,
hopefully there's a few of
you that had that question.
We got some undercover
footage of a day in the life
of David from a couple of weeks ago.
So let's take a look at this.
So there he is.
So turns out that the first thing
you need to know about a
senior principal engineer
is they still get paged and
they still have to scramble.
They have to get back to their office,
they have to drop everything,
they have to get their laptop out,
get their favorite playlist
going to help them, you know,
work through this
troubleshooting scenario.
But what's new about this case
or what's new about this week,
is David has a new teammate.
He has the AWS DevOps Agent to help him.
So he is, first thing
he does is he checks in
and before he got his laptop
out, metrics, analytics, logs,
traces analyzed, check for, you know,
deployments that may have
impacted this situation,
already found root cause identified.
It's all before David got his laptop open.
So let's see what else it can do.
Can it help us get out
of this alarm state,
resolve this incident?
So sure enough, following
has been clearly reading
David's blog about this
week in observability.
So it knows how to generate an effective,
what we call an MCM or a change document
that's gonna include pre-validation steps,
action steps, post-action steps.
And then you'll see here
that it's actually even
showing off a little bit.
The agent is providing
David with code to go ahead
and actually fix what was in
this case a bad deployment,
the code itself.
So the last thing to do here
is to actually perform the rollback
as instructed and fix the issue.
So fingers crossed, we'll
check the validation steps.
The errors are going to,
wait for it, go away.
Alright, and so we should have
a happy senior principal engineer.
So that's just a little
bit of insight into David,
but also really what the
AWS DevOps Agent does.
And so we launched AWS DevOps Agent
in public preview yesterday.
And let me ask, who here in the audience
has ever been on call, carried a pager,
been on the other side of that page?
Is that it?
Really only about half of you?
Okay, one other question
just outta my curiosity.
Is anybody here actually
on on-call right now?
Okay, well, we've got a couple
of dozen of you so you know,
if you get up and run out,
I won't take it personally.
So what does the AWS DevOps Agent do?
So it performs two fundamental tasks.
So the first I just showed you.
Helps you resolve incidents faster.
It's gonna analyze your
metrics, analytics logs
as traces that are related
to a particular incident.
Look for related deployments.
It's going to share with you its findings,
it's gonna generate a root
cause and it's gonna provide you
with mitigation steps
to resolve the issue.
So all with the goal of
helping you reduce MTTR.
The second thing, what you
didn't see in that video
is the agent is always
there, it's always available,
it's always sort of
lurking in the background,
and it's designed also to
help you prevent incidents
before they happen.
So it does that in a couple of ways.
But you know, what is able to do
is it will periodically
scan all of the incidents
that have been investigated
and managed by the agent.
It's gonna take its
understanding of things
like AWS best practices or well
architected best practices.
It's understanding of your
application environment,
and this is gonna suggest changes.
Changes to fix what it detects
is maybe under underlying problems
that created the context for
a particular set of incidents
or other opportunities it sees to improve
the posture of your application.
So how does it work?
Four things that I wanna highlight about
how the AWS DevOps Agent works.
So the first is that we've designed it
to operate as a member of your team.
If you saw the keynote yesterday,
Matt Garmin talked about frontier agents
and an aspect of a frontier agent
is it can work autonomously
as part of your team.
And so in this case, what
it can do is it can respond
just like an on-call
engineer would respond
to support tickets, pages, alarms
that you configured to trigger the agent
to perform an investigation
of a particular incident.
It can then write its findings,
communicate its findings
back into say the comment
in a ServiceNow ticket.
It can also, you know, if you're
using something like Slack
for your team to coordinate
during an incident,
it'll provide just as
any other engineer would,
its findings back into
the Slack channel itself.
We've also designed the
agent to not just work
with the people on your team.
And I'll talk about this
in a little bit more depth in a moment.
We've also designed it as an
agent to work with other agents
that you may be deploying
in your environment as well.
The second characteristic
of the DevOps Agent
that I wanna share with
you is we've designed it
to be a telemetry expert.
So we've built in integrations
with not just AWS CloudWatch
and telemetry that AWS provides,
but with our launch partners,
Dynatrace, Datadog, New Relic,
and Splunk, we've given
it access to the telemetry
and the telemetry signals
that you all have told us
that you you use and you all have told us
that you use other things too.
And a very common thing we've
heard is open source stacks
with Grafana, Prometheus,
something like Loki for example.
And so we give you a way to tie
into those self-hosted telemetry systems
or really any other
telemetry that you may have
through something that we call BYO
or bring your own MCP server.
And so with that in place, you know,
what it gives the agent the ability to do
is what you saw in that
video, which is rapidly
and quickly scan through the important
or related logs, metrics,
alarms and traces
that you have in your infrastructure.
But because it has access and
because it's also oriented
to prevent future incidents,
it will provide you with recommendations
on how to improve your
observability postures.
So that might be adding what it receives
to be missing metrics or perhaps tuning
what might be flapping
alarms, those kinds of things.
So the third characteristic
of the AWS DevOps Agent
that I wanted to highlight
is we've worked very hard
to make it what we think
of as a pipeline pro.
So often it's the case that
when an incident happens,
as a result of some kind of change.
It might be a change to
the application code,
it could be a change to
the infrastructure code.
And so we've given it access
through built-in integrations
to things like GitHub and GitLab
so it can understand
your deployment pipelines
and the repos that sit
behind those pipelines
so it can detect these changes.
And again, it's got this dual personality
of being able to react to incidents
but then also provide guidance
on how to prevent future incidents.
So in this case may make suggestions
to improve your pipelines
themselves, perhaps to add tests
or other things that will
help you prevent incidents
to begin with before they happen.
Fourth characteristic, and the last one
that I want to talk about
is it was important for us to be able
to construct this agent
so that it really knows
your apps and your organization.
So knowing your apps.
So what it will do is it'll
automatically generate
what we call an application topology.
You can think of it as a knowledge graph
or a map of your application
and your environment.
What are the important entities?
What are their relationships
with each other?
That'll help guide the agent
as it's performing its tasks.
The other thing that we recognize
is that there's some things
that are going to be unique
about your organization, your practice.
So you can provide those
to the agent in the form
of two things, what we
call steering files,
or you might think of them as runbooks
that you can directly provide
to the agents that you create.
You can also give the agents access
to existing runbooks that you may have.
So these might be coming out
of your ticketing system.
Or for example, we have customers
who told us they've maintained the runbook
in something like Confluence.
And if that's something they
wanna actually see in action,
I understand that the
Atlassian booth at five o'clock
they're gonna show you how
to connect AWS DevOps Agent
through the Atlassian
MCP server into a tool
that'll give the agent access
to the Confluence runbooks.
So having said all of that,
the one thing we've also
sort of acknowledged is that
it's important, you know,
to know that some point there's a limit
to what the agent can do.
And so that's where we
give you the ability
to bring in an expert, a human expert.
And so at any point, for
example, during an investigation
that the AWS DevOps Agent
is, you know, in the process
of completing as it's working
through findings, plan,
you know, the hypothesis
generating root cause analysis
or mitigation plans, if you wanna have
an expert's human set of eyes,
one click, you can pull
an AWS support engineer
into an investigation.
They'll be provided with
all the context stuff
up to that date, and
you can be in chatting
with not just the agent but
also an AWS support engineer
to help you refine the root cause
or basically maybe
validate mitigation steps.
So I talked about topology,
I wanted to double click
on that just for a second here.
This is a picture of what
an application topology
looks like in the AWS DevOps
Agent web application.
So what is it?
So, you know, how this is created.
It starts from the ground up.
When you set up your AWS DevOps Agent,
you create what's called an agent space.
And within that agent
space, you give it access
to one or multiple cloud accounts.
And we'll start discovering the resources
that you've given us
access to through IM roles
and the relationships with each other.
The agent will then start to,
will continue to maintain that.
We'll look for additional relationships.
If you've given it access
to a telemetry source,
it'll bring in their service maps.
It'll map like say log groups, metrics,
alarms into entities in your topology.
If you've given it access
to your CICD pipelines,
it'll map deployments into entities.
So it builds up this structure
or this map of your architecture
that helps it, you know,
during an incident, narrow in
and refine, say log queries
or metric queries that it needs to do
to determine what's going
on in a particular incident.
It'll also use this application map
and compare it to
patterns, say for example,
in AWS best practices
patterns that it knows
are well architected principles
as well as any guidance
that you've given it
through the steering files
for your own guidelines and policies.
And it'll look for deviations from that
and use that form part
of its recommendations
or what I called earlier the
prevention recommendations.
So last thing I want to
talk about is, you know,
how this is, you know,
the success that customers
have had with the AWS
DevOps Agents so far,
and then I'm gonna turn it over to David
to demo the solution to you.
But the first thing I wanna
say, you're probably wondering,
we released it yesterday,
how could I have customer
examples of this?
But we actually started back in August,
we gave a AWS DevOps
Agent, we made it available
to internal Amazon and AWS teams
to use in their on-call rotations
to help them improve the posture
of their applications and services.
And so far today the AWS DevOps Agent
internally has handled over
a thousand real live Amazon
and AWS, you know, application
and service team incidents.
And we carefully track each of those.
We work those manually with the teams
that have the actual on calls
that have been responding
to those incidents.
And we've determined that
the AWS DevOps Agent to date
has been able to achieve
an 86% success rate
on its root cause analyses.
So two things about that,
86%, it's a B, right?
And so, you know, we're
certainly after an A here,
and so we are continuing to work
on improving this every day.
But one thing that you
know, was pointed out to me
by some of our customers is
that don't beat yourself up
too much over that 14%
because even when the agent
is getting it wrong or
maybe has an incomplete RCA,
it's gone down pathways, right,
and shown its work in
terms of the log analysis
that it may have done
or the metric analysis
that it may have done.
And those are pathways
that I would've gone down,
dead ends that I as an on-call
engineer would've gone down,
and so you saved me a lot of time
even if in the end you
didn't get it right.
So a couple of other examples here.
So we did open it up then in September
to external beta customers.
One of the first customers
that we made it available to
was the Commonwealth Bank of Australia.
And the first thing they
did, they got it set up
and they said, let's
give it something tricky.
Like they said, we had a network outage
a couple of days ago,
or not a network outage,
a network incident of
some type that took them
and their team a little over
five hours to root cause.
And so what they did is they
gave the AWS DevOps Agent
the same context that their
teams had a couple days prior
and asked it to figure it out.
And what came back in 15 minutes
was an accurate RCA analysis.
So really happy with what we're seeing,
what our customers are seeing
in some real world scenarios.
Last thing I wanted to point
out to you all, you know,
as a result of the customer
experience in the beta,
as I mentioned earlier, that we're making
the AWS DevOps Agents something that works
with not just other people,
other on-call engineers
and other SREs DevOps
engineers on your team,
but also with other agents.
And so we worked with some of
our launch partners on this
and here's an example of
of one of them, Dynatrace,
where we targeted jointly
a couple of customers.
You see Clariant, a chemical
manufacturing company.
Western Governors University,
if you haven't heard of them,
they have about 200,000
students, United Airlines,
who many of you probably
flew here to get here.
These were joint Dynatrace
and Amazon customers
where we worked with them
to set up AWS DevOps Agent
to work in concert with Dynatrace
and particularly Dynatrace's
Davis AI capabilities.
And so Western Governors is
a great example that I like
to highlight in less than a
day, they were able to get
both of these systems, these
solutions, these agents
up and running and working
collaboratively together
in their production
environments to help them
investigate in this particular
case real world incidents.
So that's the introduction.
It's time now to turn it over to David
who's gonna walk you through
in detail what the agent,
the AWS DevOps Agent can do.
(audience applauds)
- Alright, so yeah,
picture's a thousand words.
So let's just look at a
whole bunch of examples
of the DevOps Agent
going and doing things.
So we'll actually show
you four different demos.
We'll start with another
kind of slow motion version
of that fast motion video where I was,
had that started with the
pager, which I still have.
Hopefully it doesn't go off
while we're having this presentation.
I might have to investigate something.
It's not going to, I'm just, okay.
But then we'll also look
at customizing DevOps Agent
with bringing MCP servers.
I'll show you how you can steer it
and nudge it in a direction
or ask questions about with chat.
And then I'll show that
future issue prevention
where it scans past incidents
to look for patterns of things
that you can improve long
term to prevent future issues.
Okay, first demo time.
Now throughout, we're gonna
look through a set of services
that I built that work together
called Robots-as-a-service service.
This is, you can imagine
this is a set of web services
that talk to each other that make it
so you can control
robots like in the world.
Like you can send them commands,
schedule them to do things,
see where they are and whatnot.
I actually created this,
it's a set of microservices,
like a gateway service,
the bot service that talks
to a schedule service that talks
to the action service to go
and use AWS IoT to send
commands to the robots.
And then a forge service
that you would use
for provisioning.
This is simple, but
it's also each of these
are internally complex.
There are a lot of different
things, security groups,
load balancers, autoscaling
groups, all acles,
I don't all kinds of stuff
that actually make up these things.
IM roll.
So lots of things that
could potentially go wrong.
So less talk, more action.
Let's get into it.
So let's start by implementing a bug
and pushing it to production.
Here I am in Kiro.
I have this caching logic
in the forge service
and I'm gonna say let's
add a timestamp field
to the cache records just to,
because maybe I need to measure
how effective my cache is,
how long things are cached for.
Harmless change.
We're just adding data, it's
not gonna cause any problems.
So let's just push that.
Fantastic.
And in the distance, alarms.
So, okay, so things break.
So in this case I'm using
Dynatrace for my kind
of application level
monitoring and alerting.
And sure enough it goes and it detects
the problem automatically.
It's pretty nice, these Davis alarms.
They kinda just, I didn't
have to set anything up.
Finds, sees the failure rate increase
and sure enough, yep, problems,
bot services, seeing errors.
I can see overall that there are problems
kind of throughout the stack.
All the services are kind of lighting up
with bad failure rates, so not good.
So in the meantime, Dynatrace
has called a web hook
that sent this notification
to the AWS DevOps Agent.
So before I didn't
necessarily even need to be
to show up here and look at it,
it already kicked off an investigation.
In this case, this is the operator app
within the AWS DevOps Agent.
So I go here and I see all my ongoing
and past investigations.
Let's go ahead and look at this one
to see kind of the details.
So here we can see, oh, you don't need
to use the chat for right now.
We'll come back to that.
So, here we see the issue.
This is what Dynatrace Davis
sent the AWS DevOps Agent.
You can see the details of the
problem, where the problem is
and extremely precise timestamp
of when the problem occurred there.
So that's really helpful.
And so let's go from here.
Let's just like jump to the end
from like a storing standpoint.
Let's go right to the root cause.
So at the end, this
investigation's already complete.
Like by the time I made
it back into the office
and opened my laptop, the
investigation was done.
And so what is the root
cause in this case?
Well, it says a code deployment
introduced a cache serialization format
incompatibility in the bot-forge service.
And this is exactly what
you saw me implement.
I added a new, it says I
added a new timestamp field
that's with the code change
and the deserialization method.
So it understood the surrounding code
that the deserialized method
didn't like to see this new field.
So, it was failing.
And so it also talked, said that,
well, actually the requests
that were cache misses,
the ones that went right
to DynamoDB succeeded.
So that's actually an
interesting kind of nuance
that it noticed while
doing the investigation
that some request for succeeding.
It wasn't obvious, but it's useful
from figuring out useful evidence
to prove that this, yes, this
code change was the problem.
So great, let's go back up the top
and see how the agent got there.
We're gonna scroll through slowly here.
So it started off, it said,
okay, I'm gonna investigate.
Let's start by just kind of figuring out
where we are in the world.
It's gonna goes, read some runbooks.
These are all MCP tool calls.
You notice since I'm using Dynatrace,
it's doing DQL queries.
I could, if I want to inspect
and see what it's been up to,
I'm clicking on one of the details
and it's showing me the inputs and outputs
of each of those MCP calls to.
And then so fantastic, it
runs a bunch of queries.
Just get figuring out what's going on.
Now it has between calling Dynatrace
and querying our own kind of internally
figured out version of your topology.
It says, okay, here's
what we're dealing with,
here are the services,
here's what talks to what.
Let's keep going.
So next it's gonna continue to triage,
kinda understand the health
of each of those services.
And it says, okay, yep,
the front end service
is seeing errors.
It's having errors
talking to dependencies.
So it's kind of gonna look for
a needle in a different haystack.
Okay, let's go investigate those services.
Those services are also seeing errors,
but they're talking to
the bot-forge service,
which is seeing errors.
So let's go move search for a
needle in a different haystack
and says, okay, fantastic.
Bot-forge seems like the
most dependent service.
Let's go.
Let's now zoom in on bot-forge
and really interrogate that
to see what's going on.
And so it's bot-forge, it's
calling AWS APIs through MCP,
it's calling its own topology
and now it has figured
out the AWS resources
and other, just everything that makes up
like what pipelines are
deploying to this service,
where are its logs, let's just figure out
how we zoom in and explore this thing.
Okay, so let's, from there now we have
a lot of investigations we need to do.
So he comes up with a lot of ideas.
Okay, let's search the
bot-forge deployments
and infrastructure changes
to see if we just changed something.
Let's look at the EC2
instance health metrics
to see if maybe there's,
we ran out of something
like a file descriptors or CPU.
Let's check other components
like the bot config
DynamoDB table that this uses to see
if it's running out of
capacity or something.
Let's look at application logs and zoom in
to see if there's any hints there.
And actually let's look
at traffic patterns
to see maybe there's some incoming shift
that's causing some problem here.
Some new robots being added or asked for.
Who knows?
These are kind of, I
find from my experience
that these are the kind
of key beats to look for
when you're trying to
figure out what to mitigate
'cause each of these
can map to a mitigation.
We're running out of CPU,
let's add more servers.
If we deployed something, let's roll back.
So these kind of map to
things that can be mitigated.
Okay, so, but that's a lot to look for.
So the agent is actually,
has listed all these
things it wants to do,
but it's gonna do this in parallel.
It has a lot more hands than I do,
so instead of me doing
one thing at a time,
it's just gonna investigate everything,
so it uses a subagents.
Now we're not gonna look at the output
of each individual
subagent as it goes along.
We're just gonna see,
look at the observations,
the key things that it has figured out.
Okay, so, and these
are the types of things
that get pushed to like a Slack channel.
So it says aha, there's
been a cloud formation stack
deployment with a new
launch template version.
This was created.
And it's interesting, like the agent
likes to do a little bit
of extra credit sometimes
and it says, okay, well, and it found
during this cloud formation stack update,
here are the instances that
were added and replaced.
The way I do deployments in this fleet
is I replace my instances
kind of blue green with deployments.
And it noticed that it says,
okay, here's an instance
that started here, here
when it had errors.
It's pretty neat.
Okay, what else does it
notice observation wise?
It actually is looking at a lot of things
and giving me the evidence
that it has ruled things out.
This is what Bill was talking about.
It's useful that it kind of also tells you
what it looked at that it
thinks is not important.
And it's actually kind of
interestingly clever about that.
For example, it noticed
here below it just found
that there's a CPU spike
on one of the instances,
which is suspicious and
correlates in time but irrelevant
because this is an instance
that just started up.
So of course it's gonna use a lot of CPU
as it does whatever installation
of software and everything.
So it's nice, it just, okay,
we saw this, we're gonna ignore it.
Okay, so this is just all of
the evidence that it found.
It also found looking at log files,
wherever the log files were,
it found them and noticed
some stack traces.
This is where it starts to get some hints
of the root cause of this.
Here's the line of code
according to the logs
that seems to be having some problems.
Okay, more observations.
It's pushing these Slack and stuff.
What else happened here?
It's found the rolling
instance replacement.
So it see, yeah, these are the instances
that started up and were shut down.
It also noticed, this is
where it observed that
from the logs that the requests
that were cache misses succeeded.
So that's just really
interesting details as aha,
there is definitely something wrong
with the cache interaction here, okay?
And then sure enough,
here's the code deployment.
It is connected to my GitHub actions
that I'm using to actually
drive the code changes,
not just the cloud formation part
of the infrastructure change.
And this is where it really under kind
of did this fusion of, okay,
based on what I know about the logs
and based on the code that changed,
here's what I think is
starting to really happen.
So great, all the subagent are done
and it's going to come
up with just kind of pull
all that data together and think it
come to the right conclusions from that.
And then we're back at the root cause,
which is what we talked about before.
So great, I figured it out.
Now there's actually, if I were to really
just jump to this from Slack,
the first thing I would
look at if the investigation
is done is the root cause.
This is where it's just
formatted a little bit nicer.
I don't have to scroll through like a ton
of raw findings and things like that.
So it just says that here's the impact,
there's a failure rate increase.
It then talks about here's
that same root cause text
that I showed you before.
Here's the root cause.
Cause there we already saw this.
It's that the cache serialization issue.
And then it shows the kind
of key observations below it.
The observations.
These are the key findings
that kind of prove
that this root cause.
There could be multiple root causes.
In this case, it's just one.
It says, okay, yep,
there's that evidence about
the failure rate of the cache
hits versus cache misses.
It talks about the code that was changed
and it talks about the
cloud formation stack update
that was part of the code change
that actually made it into production.
Great.
So there's that root cause.
Okay, but root cause is great,
but we need to fix the problem.
So here's where we can
generate a mitigation plan.
We ask it to, okay, like what should we do
In this case it's gonna be pretty simple
because it's a bad deployment.
So what do you do when
there's a bad deployment?
Well, you roll it back.
So it's this rollback.
But I hadn't actually
until I was using this,
doing this demo, I
didn't really know about,
I hadn't used GitHub actions before,
so this is teaching me for the first time
how to do a rollback.
Now it breaks things
down into how I change.
Whenever you're gonna do
anything in production,
you wanna do things very carefully.
You wanna prepare, make sure
you have everything in order first,
pre validate, make sure
the system hasn't changed
in the meantime, when you kind
of have this first idea about
what to do, you need to
prepare and then make sure,
did somebody else on my
team roll back already?
Did we learn something new
in the last five minutes?
So you just do all those
careful preparation, then apply.
This is where I didn't really know how
to do GitHub actions rollbacks
before, this taught me.
And it it showed me what to expect.
Then after you do that, it says,
here's some commands
you can run if you want
to make sure that the
change is rolling back
and that you're seeing
the recovery you expect.
And of course if that
goes wrong, then you want
to be prepared ahead of
time to undo the thing
that you just did.
In this case, rolling back the rollback.
So, put the bad, potentially
bad code in back in place
and then figure out what to do from there,
which will be a real exciting journey.
Now, I would look at this later,
but this is the long term solution.
I don't wanna be distracted by this.
I need to kick off the rollback.
But the long term solution,
it repairs this spec
of what I can do to hand
to say a coding agent
or just do myself.
It says, here's how you
should actually fix the code.
You wanna make sure you have good tests
and that you update the deserializer
to match the serializer.
Okay, but let's focus on rollback.
So let's go over to GitHub
actions where I can do that
and this, I'm just kind
of following that runbook.
It says, okay, this is actually,
this is the bad deployment.
The adding the timestamped
was the problem.
So let's go back.
And so the problem was that,
or the thing we wanna roll
back to is the actually last,
that's last known good deployment.
So click on that and rerun all jobs.
There's nothing special in the agent
that knows about GitHub actions.
It just kind of knows that
'cause it's an LLM frankly.
And so it's just a, it teaches me how
to use GitHub actions to do the rollback.
And this is just one example of a thing
that it would figure out.
And so just confirm, I can go
to whatever observability tool
I'm using, in this case Dynatrace.
Hit that refresh, and then
we are back to healthy.
So there it is.
That's going through an investigation.
So now, oh, and it shows there,
the Davis problems have been cleared.
So that's great.
Now let's do that follow up.
Let's fix the bug so
that we don't, you know,
you come into this problem again.
So I copy the spec, which is at the bottom
of that mitigation actions page.
And then I like to use Kiro for the using
its spec driven development.
It does kind of production
changes pretty well
without and while keeping
the fun of vibe coating.
And so I paste that in.
Kiro is gonna generate
its own specification,
its own, okay, here are
the full requirements.
I'm gonna go spend some time
understanding your code.
Maybe it's a code I didn't
have to author with Kiro.
It'll just I'll just learn
about your code base,
come up with a plan.
I'll read the req, come
with detailed requirements
that say how I should make the change,
come up with a design and
I can review the design.
I'm not showing you all this.
And then come up with a
timeline, oh, excuse me,
a task list of things
that it's going to do
one thing at a time.
And I can say, okay, implement it.
I actually used Kiro to implement
a lot of the things here.
So it works really well for this.
And then it also generates
really nice tests
because you have that specification
that says the requirements of things
that you wanna make sure you have.
Kiro generates property
based tests to make sure
it's not just kind of no op unit tests.
It does very thorough tests on
because it understands the behavior
that you want to have
through the specification.
So it can generate really nice tests.
So that's the end to end fix
on a typical incident for me
is you react to it, you mitigate it
and then you solve the root cause.
So the flow of this, so why
didn't we build this before?
Like why didn't we just build
DevOps Agent like a decade ago?
It's because like DevOps is messy.
It's a mix of so many different
tools and systems together
that were never really designed
to interact, interface with each other.
Like sure, they all have APIs.
Like when APIs, web
services became a thing,
like you can make
anything talk to anything
by like coding the integration.
But there are just so
many, it's like end to m.
Like there's so many combinations of tools
that you might use
together for deployment,
observability, logs,
metrics, traces, who knows?
And so, the key unlock
for why we can do this now
is thanks to LLMs and MCP
and that kind of thing.
So you saw the bad code change,
in this case flow through GitHub,
through cloud formation, EC2 service,
use Dynatrace, use CloudWatch,
Slack for to talk to me,
ServiceNow to page me.
All these things that all
need to play together.
And so you, I'm sure you can kind of map,
you might use some of these tools,
you might use a different set of tool
for a different type of thing.
So that's the, the flexibility is key.
Okay, so how did it actually do this?
Like under the hood, what's going on?
Well, the objective of incident management
is to find some hidden
gem, the root cause, right?
You've gotta find the thing.
Something that you can do something about.
So the agent gets just kind
of plopped into a desert,
says, hey, go, go find that hidden gem
with really no instruction.
It doesn't need any
instruction at the beginning.
So this is where it starts
by building that topology,
it needs to understand what
you have in your system.
Like what is the universe
that I might need to look at?
I don't know even know
where in the desert to look.
So okay, let's understand your system.
It learns how do I find metrics
and how do I find logs
about each of these things?
How do I find out how you're deploying?
So it surveys the
landscape and then it needs
to understand the links between.
And so this topology is the connectivity
between different resources,
different systems,
and it uses everything available
to build this topology map.
It looks as well, are you using traces?
Then I can follow traces
through the system.
Do you have IAM permissions
on this lambda function
to talk to that DynamoDB table?
Oh, okay, let's draw a line there.
It doesn't necessarily
talk to it, but I should.
It's worth looking at
during an investigation.
And then it learns how to drill down.
It says, okay, do I know how
to zoom in on this service
and break it down and see it,
look at all the host metrics
and everything, all the little things.
So that's ultimately what it's doing
behind the scenes as pictured here.
Okay, let's look.
So, what we saw?
We saw an investigation happen,
it interfaced with a
ton of different tools.
It provided all of its evidence,
maybe more than you needed,
and it gave safe mitigation
steps really thoughtfully
because you're about to mitigate something
by doing a production
change kind of on the fly.
So you need to be ready for that
and review that and break it down.
So that's that.
Okay, demo two, MCP servers.
Bring your own MCP
server and customization.
Like I said, you probably
use some combination
of these types of tools or
totally different tools.
Let's do another where
instead of sending our traces
to Dynatrace and logs and
metrics to CloudWatch,
let's say you have some,
your own log store.
So let's say you have a log store,
maybe it's an S3 or something,
and then you send your
traces to CloudWatch,
whatever, let's mix it up.
Use different observability tools.
Well, how would the agent know how,
it doesn't know about your
bespoke logging system,
so how would it do that?
Well, the answer is to just
add an and pop up an MCP server
and then configure the agent to use it.
I did this in like 20 minutes with,
I actually implemented
this and you'll see it.
I using Amazon Bedrock
agent, core MCP gateway.
I just stood up a gateway,
talks to a Lambda function
and queries my S3 logs.
I used Kiro specs to
generate it and it was done.
Maybe let's get say 40
minutes, just end to end.
Okay, great.
So here's another failure.
Let's cause another problem.
So here I am, same
bot-forge service setup.
Lemme just log into
one of these instances.
I'm gonna SSH into one of 'em.
Maybe I'm like troubleshooting
some latency issue.
I don't know. Let's say, oh, I'm seeing,
I'm gonna pick on the cache again.
Let's say there's,
I'm seeing something weird with the cache.
Let's just go into the
cache and clear the files.
Like I think that might fix the problem.
Just remove the cache.
Yeah, maybe that's a good idea.
I don't know.
And again, maybe not a good idea.
It depends on how it works.
So it wasn't a good idea.
And so here we have the investigation
that triggered off of a CloudWatch alarm.
So in this case it was triggering off
a CloudWatch alarm on a load balancer.
So now it's the tools are different.
The flow is the same but
the tools are different.
It's getting, looking at X-ray,
it's looking at CloudWatch metrics,
it's using the topology
again, that's similar.
And it says okay, yeah,
we have a load balancer
showing errors.
Let's dig in from here and figure out
where to do that investigation.
Goes in, looks at stuff, looks at stuff.
Okay, now it found quickly
that these are the SQLite
cache table is missing
causing HTTP 500 errors.
We just figured that out.
How did it figure it out?
Well, it's sorted in
the S3 application logs.
This is that random MCP
server that didn't exist
until 40 minutes before
this that I configured
and it just knew how to
talk to it to query logs.
Pretty great and use it
contextually in the investigation.
For this service I know
how to get to its logs.
So it's great and it figured it out.
More just investigation.
It's coming to
observations, the same idea.
It just investigates and
figures out what's going on.
More metrics, more metrics,
more metrics, more metrics.
All subagents are done, so
let's synthesize the findings.
Great.
It actually noticed, I was busted.
Manual SSM session on bot-forge instance
caused SQLite database corruption.
dyanacek, who's that?
Started an SSM session and
maybe messed with some stuff.
And so sure enough it
found through CloudTrail
that I had logged into the
host before and it's like,
oh, that's suspicious,
because that's the same host
that it saw from the logs
that had the errors about the cache.
So great.
Again, I'm just showing.
The interesting thing
that I'm showing here
is that how similar the investigation
is to the past investigation.
It just happens to be
using different tools.
It's still successful.
It's just using this
custom bespoke MCP server
that I made that, you know,
if you have your own system,
you can also plug that in.
And so here it is with
the root cause manual SSM.
Session maybe messed up
the a SQL like cache.
So, let's see like how
what it comes up with.
The earlier mitigation plan was simple.
It was just a rollback.
This is a little bit more
exotic of a scenario.
What does it figure out?
It says, well, what you should do is just,
it's happening on one instance,
you should just replace it.
And that's absolutely what
I would do in this incident.
I would just first just
get the bad thing out
and then quickly like follow up with more,
figure out, make sure we understand why
and we actually do have the evidence
as to why it's 'cause I logged into it.
So similar thing, prepare, let's make sure
that the auto-scaling group that we have
all the right arms
figured out and make sure
these are the right things
we should be messing with.
Pre validate, make sure
that more instances
haven't come up bad.
Make sure that the healthy instance
is still there and healthy.
Maybe the situation has changed.
And then apply.
It also gives the, you know,
conveniently it gives the right, I would,
this is how I would terminate the instance
with autoscaling command
instead of an EC2 command.
Okay, just because this
does the graceful shutdown.
Okay, fine.
Little nuance but still useful.
And then post validate,
make sure that you have
a healthy fleet and then,
and if rollback steps
I guess are just to try
to put the fleet back
together in a good way.
Great.
So that's about that.
So what did we see?
We saw bringing a random MCP server
that can do some part of your ops.
Whether it's how you do deployments,
if you have your own deployment system,
if you have your own knowledge
base that you wanna wire in.
If you have your own
observability tool for something,
if you have like business metrics,
maybe you measure customer
impact using your own tool,
I don't know, whatever it is,
just bring it in an MCP server
using agent core gateway.
I find it to be really
easy to do that securely.
Like this agent is the only thing that is,
has permission to talk to that MCP server,
so it's not like it's just open.
It's great.
And this particular root
cause was interesting.
It was a gray failure that
we did and so it was great.
Now let's see how you can
interact with investigations
and with the DevOps Agent
outside of passively
watching what it's up to.
So you can ask questions
about investigations.
That's one thing you can do is to say,
let's say I had some investigation
and okay, say what is the start time?
Well, it's a simple question
but maybe I didn't wanna
read through and scroll,
so I can say, what was the start time?
It just answers questions
about what this chat is about.
What did the investigation already find?
So it's not gonna do
big research projects.
It's just gonna answer questions based
on what was already revealed
in the investigation.
So for example, I could say what alarms
triggered during the event.
It says, well, this is one alarm.
And it says what, by the way,
the investigation didn't
look super thoroughly.
So if you want, you would have to ask me
to go look for other alarms.
And so, okay, great.
So I might say, okay,
let's do a little bit more
of a research project.
Let's say can you summarize
the customer impact?
Maybe I want to just have a nice report
that shows a little bit more
about what the impact was.
You can see it sends
that request to the agent
and then the agent
replies with this report.
Maybe had to do a little more research
and just compile things.
And you can see just, it's a nice report.
It says here are the services,
each of their failure rates
that happened during the incident.
And just a bunch more details
about like the duration,
the timeline, customer facing impact.
It describes things in
terms of what it understands
my functionality is.
Okay, and if wanna ask a
deeper question to say, okay,
but how many robots like this
is the bot service, robot server,
how many robots were impacted during this?
I could later on figure out which robots.
Okay, how many robots were impacted?
So it's gonna have to do more queries.
It didn't query that
during the investigation,
so it's gonna take a little bit of time
to go and do a bunch of queries.
You can see it doing more
DQL queries to Dynatrace
'cause spans are the part
that are really rich
with this information.
The labels of like, this is
the robot that I was working on
and this is the status code and stuff.
Spans are really rich
with that information.
So it queries the spans and then and logs.
It's kind of again, just figuring
out what it needs to pull
to answer my question of like
which robots were impacted.
And then it answers, okay,
we found 91 unique robots
that had and here said the way
in which they were impacted.
They saw five hundreds.
They were impacted on certain operations.
It's kind of breaking that down by API.
All great because this
was all in the span data.
I don't know how it figured it out,
but I just happened to have know.
And then, yeah, it just gives a nice,
you get a nice overall summary.
This isn't something it
was specially coded to do.
I just thought it would be
a nice thing to show off.
Well, what should I ask it?
Let's ask it customer impact,
'cause it's something that I often do.
During an incident I want to see
kind of what my customers
saw when there was a problem.
It's really an important question
in the moment and then later.
Okay, you can also, when an investigation
is going on, you can nudge it.
You can steer it to say, Hey,
I think you should
actually go look at this
'cause you might not
just be sitting there.
If you do open your laptop
before the investigation is done,
you might want to go look at things
and be active in this.
So when you're looking at things
you might share things you found.
Or if you see it get off track,
you might wanna put it back on track.
Here's a real example
of a getting off track.
During when preparing
this demo for all of you,
I noticed I was doing an investigation
but I was breaking things
like every 30 minutes.
Letting it recover for a short time
and breaking something again.
And so it was confused.
It was like, oh, there are
all these different things
happening at the same time.
And so I said, can you show
me the incident timeline?
And it said, okay, well, 18:00
and then 19:00 this thing happened.
And then at 21:00 this thing happened.
And then like the 22:00.
It's finding all these different
things that I had broken.
I don't remember what I had prompted.
The next day this other thing happened.
I'm like, okay, like
agent, like can you relax
and just look at, I said, can you look at
the most recent impact only.
I said, yeah, these deployments
are way too spread out.
Can you ask the investigation to focus
on the most recent impact to see
what might have triggered that?
I think for this prompt,
initially for this investigation,
I didn't actually ask it
about a specific, you know,
alarm timestamp or
something. I don't know.
So that's why it kind of got
a little creative and said,
great, okay, I'm gonna, and it actually
like improved my prompts to the agent too.
It said actually let's get this timestamp.
I didn't paste that timestamp.
It figured out the start point in the chat
and then it pasted that to the agent
to have it look at the most recent wave.
So pretty nice way of
steering investigations
but through chat.
I can also just kind of
learn about my environment.
I don't have to ask about a specific
maybe operational issue.
We have it really tuned to ask
about like explain an alarm,
explain like why there's
a problem right now.
But you can actually ask it
really whatever you feel like.
For example, sometimes I
might start an investigation.
You can tell it what
alarm to look at here,
but I can say maybe don't
investigate anything.
I just want to ask you some questions.
Great.
And this is start an
investigation about TBD.
And so the agent responds
with, okay, I will just,
I'll help you, let me
know what you want to do.
So I might ask, can you investigate
to see what ec2 instances
I had a few minutes ago?
And this is a real thing I was doing
when preparing for this.
I just thought, what would be a neat thing
to ask and show all of you?
I didn't really realize it
was gonna be kind of neat.
So it said, okay, I'm
gonna describe instances,
look at the topology, figure it out.
It spent a little bit of time and it said,
well, here's a summary.
And it said you have
54 terminated instances
in the last 30 minutes and I
didn't know this was going on.
It said, you have instance churn happening
in your auto scaling group,
instances are coming up
and getting shut down right away.
I was like, ooh, whoops, okay.
So I didn't actually realize
it was kind of actually
a kind of fun question,
so it didn't just literally
answer my question.
It did, but then it also got a little bit
of that extra credit and it
said, well, this is funny.
Maybe you want to know why.
So it has that nice helpful
curiosity to help me,
oh yeah, okay, this is a
problem I need to go fix that.
From customers who have
been using this so far,
they've also said just
in different things,
whether they're glancing
at that noisy topology map
or they're looking at anything
during an investigation
or asking these questions.
We keep hearing that people
are always learn a little bit
something that they didn't
realize they would learn
that is interesting and
relevant in some other way.
So, it's interesting that
just that little extra
looking around corners for you.
There's so much telemetry data out there,
so much going on in logs
that's just, but you don't have time
to go look at everything all
the time but the agent does.
Another way you can influence the agent
around future investigations
are with Runbooks.
Now Runbooks are sort of
like things that will,
the agent can use and reference
when doing an investigation
to speed things up
or steer it in a certain way.
They're kind of like
today we released in Kiro
this thing called Kiro powers.
Kiro powers are, when
you're using the Kiro IDE,
they're a kind of a
combination of MCP servers
and steering files and hooks and things
that just like in a nice packaged format
that help the agent
specialize in a certain tool
that it might not just your
agents are generally good,
but like broadly good, but
to specialize in something.
It's nice to package all of that up.
And so this is the same idea.
It's runbooks, that just
little pieces of guidance
that are just loaded on demand
whenever the agent wants to look at it.
Let's look at something.
You can add one or let's look at a couple
that I find are useful.
So I decided to write one for this
that kind of just helps
the agent speed up,
maybe shave off a minute
of an investigation.
Actually I think I disabled the Runbook
and I don't think it was
helping, but it doesn't matter.
Just for demonstration purposes.
I kind of gave it an overview and said,
okay, here's where I'm
storing all of my stuff.
I was using logs in an MCP server.
I'm doing code deployments
maybe through GitHub actions in this case,
just to kinda give it a little bit
of a head start on figuring it out.
It'll wander around and
figure out what I have,
but this kind of, I just feel like
it sometimes it helps ground it.
So that's one kind of
Runbook you could write.
Just give, nudge it in
the right direction.
I gave it a little bit of a Runbook
for that bespoke MCP server for logs
that I've been talking about.
I found that the agent, it
was using the MCP server okay
but it kept querying for
the current minute of logs.
Like the right now, like
if it's like two o'clock,
it was looking for logs
from two o'clock and I said,
Ooh, actually I only push my logs
like with a two minute delay,
so only look for logs two minutes ago.
And all that does is save a
little bit of a back and forth.
It figures it out, but it's still.
I just give it a little
bit more information
about how to use the tool.
Often that information is in
the MCP tool documentation,
but whatever you can, it
doesn't matter where you put it.
I also said, oh yeah,
a good logging service
like CloudWatch logs will
just package up stack traces
and everything into the same line.
In my case, you could,
my MCP server let you grip for errors,
but it didn't return
any data after that line
that it gripped and found, so I said,
Hey, don't forget to ask
for extra lines after,
so that you can actually
see the stack trace.
So, I just gave it some tips.
The details aren't super important.
This is just how you can
give the agent a little bit
of hint if you see in the details like,
why didn't it get to
this thing fast enough?
Oh, let me help it next time.
So great.
That's, you can use Runbooks
and to influence future investigations.
You can learn about your
environment and chat and you can,
yeah, and you can actually just
learn about your environment
by just talking with it.
Okay, let's now talk about
preventing future incidents,
which sounds impossible, but it is.
So one thing that DevOps
Agent does is prevention.
If you go into the top of the ops council,
there's a prevention of the operator app.
There's a prevention tab.
And what this does is
just in the background,
there's no real hurry, but in
the background it's looking at
your past incidents to look for patterns
of like what seems to be going wrong
that I can recommend you change
that could prevent this class
of issue from happening again.
So in this case, I had been injecting
a bunch of failures into this environment
and it looked at the
last, in this case 19,
and gave some recommendations.
The recommendations are categorized.
They're like governance things,
infrastructure
recommendations, observability.
Notice it has no
observability recommendations.
I used to work on CloudWatch,
so I'm pretty good at that.
So I guess I passed the
test for observability.
Great.
Let's look at some examples
of what it did find.
Just a bunch of stuff.
I found some health
check stuff I should do.
Let's just explore a few of these.
One is configure the
mininstances in service.
They found some auto-scaling setting
that I had screwed up
at one point in time.
It said, Hey, there was
this change you made
where you configured
your auto-scaling group
in a dangerous way.
It didn't immediately cause a problem,
but you made it so in certain cases
it could replace all of your
instances at the same time.
I don't want that.
So this might have prevented
me an outage from happening.
It's like you should change it
to be the safer configuration
of your autoscaling group to avoid that
if it were to happen.
That way, it would keep instances
in service all the time.
Okay, that's great.
You could avoid an outage with that.
I'll take that.
And it gives some details
on what I should do
and how to make that change and where,
and that kind of thing.
Where to look in your, it
knows about the CDK stack
and here's where you should change it.
And I could paste this
and give that to Kiro
or some coding agent.
Alright, another type
of thing that I found
in this case was it noticed.
Oh yeah, these, I didn't
show you this failure mode,
but I had kept messing with
my DynamoDB table permissions
and it was finding this just fine.
So it was saying, okay,
somebody 10 times has,
that was me just testing
this over and over again
has keeps breaking your
DynamoDB table policy
denying permissions and
messing up everything.
And so the recommendation for this
that it gave was
actually, hey, you should,
well, it gives all the affected incident.
And it was just telling me,
Hey, like lock your permissions down.
Don't let this Deanna
check person keep breaking
your permissions on your
DynamoDB table. (chuckles)
So then another one, it said, okay,
implement post-deployment
health validation
with automatic rollback to
prevent defective deployments
from causing service failures.
This was, it noticed that I had broken
the ping health check, so
it just had a syntax error
in my ping health check
logic and that was making it
so my instances were launching
and getting terminated,
launching, terminated, and
said, well, you should fix that
and you should also, you should add checks
to make sure if you
break it in the future,
that it will get rolled
back automatically.
So it's not only is it
saying fix this problem
but also prevent it, this class of problem
by having an automatic rollback.
Great idea.
This incident now this, remember
when I said my instances
were churning, like they were
getting replaced all the time?
That's what this was actually recommending
the long term fix for
that for fixing that.
So it was very nice.
It kind of links all links all up, great.
So let's look at an, oh yeah,
yeah, implement auto rollback
and this is, and it knows about my code.
It says, here is what you should change
your launch script to do
and here's how to make
it do the auto rollback.
So, pretty convenient.
Last thing was it just found
this whole class of problems.
I kept pushing those cache breaking bugs
and said somebody keeps
pushing bad code changes.
They keep making it to production.
Can you write some tests and like,
have good responsible CICD going on here?
It's like, good idea.
Okay, so sure.
That doesn't make for as good of a demo.
But yeah, that's the thing.
So it says, let's put some blockers
in your pipelines, your
deployment pipelines.
Let's add some tests to
make sure that you're on,
you're testing your gamma environment,
your pre-prod before prod,
and if you do break things
in prod, make it auto rollback.
So just gimme some nice
recommendations there
to just have better operational posture.
So the prevention part, it
kinda is finding improvements
to my operational posture
based on what it notices
about the things that
seem to keep breaking.
When it looks at all the past
incidents and investigated
and looks for patterns of
things that you should improve.
Great.
So, Bill, you wanna wrap
us up and talk about
how to get everybody
started with everything?
- Yeah, so thank you, David, for that,
and for all of you to be here.
So we, as I mentioned earlier,
we launched in public preview yesterday.
And so what that means is it's available
as a service in the AWS console.
You can go there, get it
set up, search on Google,
you'll find the docs, you'll
find there's some links there
that have provided for you and try it out.
Public preview means it's free to use.
You might have some charges
like if you're, you know,
the actions that the agent takes to query
some of your logs and traces.
If those generate expense,
you may have some expense,
but we won't charge you
for the agent itself.
There are some limits.
So you get 20 per account that you set up
per set of agents that you deploy.
You get 20 hours of
investigation time per month
and 15 hours of prevention time per month.
So plenty to give it a try.
So super easy to set up.
I hope you saw that.
It has a lot of power already.
I'll anticipate the first question.
Are we thinking about
giving it the ability
to actually take actions
in your environment?
The answer is yes, that's
something that we're working on,
but we want to step into that closely.
You should be able to
see that there's a lot
of promise there, but give it a try.
You can get it set up running
in a couple of AWS accounts
with literally, in just
a couple of clicks.
Start asking a question,
seeing you know what it can do.
Throw alarms at it, throw questions at it.
I'd love to get you trying it
out and give us your feedback.
So again, thank you for your time.
(audience applauds)
We have a few minutes for questions
and we can take some
questions on the side after.